[Music]
all right parker you ready
[Music]
do it
exclusively in cinemas
tom the floor is yours
hi everyone i am tom holland you might
recognize me as your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and i am here to
tell you that spidey's back for an
all-new adventure in spider-man their
way home i know people say this a lot
but i mean it when i say that you're
gonna see things in this movie that
you've never ever seen before i'm
talking about pumpkin bombs
sandstorm
the multiverse which okay you might have
seen them before but i promise not like
this and not together also peter parker
is finally heading off to college and
the word is out so yeah everyone knows
that he is spider-man
so throw your fan theories out the
window they're probably not true or are
they
and get ready to see one of the most
ambitious films we've ever made an
incredible story with lots of heart
laughter high flying action mind-blowing
effects and some insane villains no way
home is the culmination of the
homecoming trilogy and the start of a
multiverse of possibilities do you know
peter parker who's spider-man yes is
that him no
can you please explain what is going on
after i shut that spell down we started
getting visitors from every universe
multiverse is real
i need you to capture them before they
destroy the fabric of reality i'm gonna
need some help
you guys ready let's catch some
multiverse men
spider-man your way home what was your
name again dr otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name
where are we going i don't know your
house oh my god okay i think i really
like them no well not anymore
hello peter do i know you we started
getting some visitors from every
universe this is all my fault
i promise i'll fix this
we're gonna get through this
i'm gonna get to it together
december 17th tickets on sale now dude
tickets on sale now dude tickets on
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby-doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
but there has to be another way there
isn't they're a danger to our universe
you know to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
and everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively at movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]